we're talking about most embarrassing
moments from high school so mortified
that he saw that [ __ ] on deck man at
home we had a lot of cats I went to
school one day and every time I would go
to class in between classes I kept
smelling [ __ ] and but then when I was in
class it went away and then the minute I
would I would go get ready to go to my
next class oh my god there is that [ __ ]
smell again it smells awful and then
about halfway through the day I was
walking down the hallway and I looked at
my backpack and the straps of my
backpack one of my cats had [ __ ] all
over the belt like the buckle part on
there and it was deep in the cracks in
there kind of had a lot of cats growing
up so you couldn't keep track on a woman
get pregnant and you wouldn't know that
they had babies until like a new cat
would walk out in your report that's not
ours but then it was yours he was the
music director of my high school
musicals but he was only like a year and
a half older so it wasn't creepy I was a
big fan of Vanilla Ice and I asked my
hairdresser that's right I went to the
same hairdresser as my mother
her name was Maxine I didn't think it
was worried that I was the only fella
there I asked her to shave something in
the back of my head and we couldn't
think of anything cool so I just had
just shaved my name and so she's back
there and she's like I feel up for a
minute and then she's like I'm done and
she turned me around and she just my
name is Pete
she had just written PE T she thought
she was done she just did a really big
pet P
my head and then we were like my name is
Pete not Pat this is time for Tizen is
it a high a lifetime high teasin for
some reason I don't think I got really
embarrassed in high school but now
looking back on numerous stories I'm
horrified mine has to be my prom career
it's not a moment it's a whole career
because you have a couple of chances at
prom
Junior Prom if you're cool enough and
then senior prom everybody go to senior
prom unless you're like sick with mono
or something I mean I think of a few
embarrassing moments involving and nuns
where I was caught reading the Bible
upside down which I guess was they
thought it was borderline sort of
satanic worship style on Valentine's Day
once I I came to school and everybody in
my classic rushed up to me and they're
like somebody left you a Valentine on
your desk boy who's in love with me and
so this whole mass of maybe like 20 25
students all followed me to my desk
there was an envelope there and I opened
it up and it was a letter from a guy in
my class his mom wrote me a letter
asking me if I would like to go to the
movies with her son in high school I got
super into Frank Sinatra music and so I
was like oh is my thing and I went to
this graduation party my friends have a
graduation party there was a band
playing and I was like excuse me guys do
you guys know more my Frank Sinatra more
than the greatest love the world has
know the first work in my mouth and I
was like this is fake people just
looking like why did you do this I don't
know not only did I choose to dance to a
stripper song I also clearly did not
have a big part in the performance in
the first place we tried to put a tiny e
so it looked like that E
but the E was so messed up that it
looked like an F and that's where I got
my nickname head F